I'm Douglas Tyrell I'm an actor and I'm
a filmmaker and I want to share a few
lessons that uh that I think every
first-time director should know and that
will serve you really well on your first
project
I think the first thing you should do is
read and research read at least two
books use the books as mentors there's a
level experience that you just don't
have as a first-time director and by
reading a few books you get so many you
get so much information on things to do
and things not to do from how to direct
a scene to how not to direct a scene
what seems to never film things you
should never do from positions and crew
and people on you and your crew that you
must have where to save money where to
spend your money what to do with
locations and those are things that you
know if you've directed multiple
projects you had that experience and you
you can apply it to your project but
when you've never directed a film it's a
it's a label it's a level of experiences
you just don't have and by using the
books as mentors and developing and
reading and getting some research out of
them you you use them as mentors and
they give you confidence when you direct
a film
talk to directors who have more
experience than you I was so blessed to
talk to friends of mine who had directed
really successful films and had a lot
more experience to me and they sit down
with me and they gave me the do's and
don'ts and the lessons they gave me they
served me incredibly well when I came to
set and they made me feel like an
experienced director because I was able
to steal some of their experiences and
use them as a way to build myself as a
new director to develop my own voice as
a director and you'll feel so much more
confident when you come to set knowing
that at least you kind of have a sky
post and a roadmap of things to do and
things not to do so read and research
I think the next most important thing
you need to do as a first-time director
is storyboard your film storyboarding
and knowing how to stage your actors is
probably here a homework as a director
and storyboarding doesn't have to be
really complex it could be like stick
figures and that's what I did I drew out
stick figures with my film and then I
hired somebody off a Fiverr to kind of a
storyboard artist to kind of you know
render them really nicely for me and you
don't have to do that I do that because
I'm a little OCD and I wanted to I
wanted to give something really
professional to my DP and the rest of my
team but you know the most important
thing is for you to have an idea of what
each shot needs to be when you write a
story you don't really see it frame by
frame you kind of see it as this
polished movie in your head but in
actuality when you're shooting it you're
shooting it frame by frame take bite
take scene by scene it builds the film
in your head you realize you know one
you have too many shots for a particular
scene
you realize this is how I want to stage
my actors this is where I want to move
my actors storyboarding is just critical
in developing your language and how
you're going to speak to your DP are you
going to speak to the rest of your team
how you're going to speak with your
actors because once you storyboard your
film it keeps building your confidence
it's a first time director because you
know your film but it also tells you how
to stage your your actors where you want
a map you know your actors want you to
know that you know where to put them at
you want to come to said saying this is
how I want to shoot the scene and this
is where I want the actors to come from
and you know you want to be flexible and
and and you want to be able to change
things up if things don't work but you
need just a starting base and that
visual language of storyboarding your
film allows you to talk to your DP on
how you want to shoot your film and he
can use his expertise and give you
suggestions on camera lenses on dolly
shots on simplifying a shot
it lets him know how many shots are
gonna be in the scene how many shots are
gonna be in the day how is he gonna
approach it it's probably one of the
most time-consuming things you can
probably do but probably one of the most
valuable things you can do because you
finally you take a story that's written
in words and you turn it into pictures
and you need to draw those pictures you
need to create those pictures to realize
how you're going to tell that story so
you get all these creative ideas when
you storyboard to film that allow you to
basically communicate your story to
everybody to your team into your actors
and storyboarding to me is just really
important it really is your homework as
a director I think every director but
every first-time director has to
storyboard their film
get a really good DP a really good ad a
great production manager and a really
really good production designer your DP
is worth its weight in gold as a
first-time director at least for me I
was intimidated by the whole idea of
directing the film but myself like I
said I had a lot of experience as an
actor but there's a lot of technical
things about it about directing a film
that he just you just don't know like
pacifically the camera the lenses you
know I was you know I would get kind of
freaked out about what lens do I use for
what shot and if if I want my scene to
look like this which is a why what lens
do I need to know that but your DP text
takes care of a lot of the technical
things that you are that you just don't
have that you don't you don't know and
they they support you and they support
the story in so many different ways they
give you suggestions they're creative
they're incredibly creative and how they
shoot the scene how they light the scene
every time I look when I was going
through the post the editing phase of my
my webseries it I see I see the scenes
and I see his work and his work it was
just amazing you know we as actors or as
directors we forget that there's other
creatives in the process of of making a
film and when you're a first-time
director once you direct a film for the
first time you realize how many other
creatives are part of a part of a
project and how many talented people
there are and how many talented people
it takes to make a project so it really
is a tribe that makes the film DPS are
amazing
get a really good ID a good ad is the
taskmaster of your film and they they
take care of all the logistics that you
can focus on and you need a D who is
responsible punctual who has
follow-through we can get things done
who has experience in being professional
you know obviously your budget is going
to be limited as a first-time project
and a first-time director but there are
there people out there who are
professional and who want to be a DS and
who can do the job so get a good ad
get a really good production manager
kind of like an ad they're gonna support
you in many other ways that you need to
be supported making sure that catering
is being handled and you think oh oh
just I'm just gonna you know give
everybody a bunch of granola bars you do
that for about three days and by the
fourth day you're gonna have me on your
set you need to feed your crew and your
actors and you've as a first-time
director you've got so much on your
plate that you can't be worrying about
you know ordering burritos and tacos for
people a good production manager is
going to make sure that lunch is always
on time there's water on set when you
need there's coffee in the morning these
little things allow you to focus on what
you need to get done and they're vital
for a project and I got that information
from a director who gave me his time and
said you know make sure you get a good
PM your pn is critical make sure that
they know what they're doing because if
you get a bad PM it could it could be
really difficult for your project
and then get a good production designer
a good production designer is gonna take
a little bit of money and just make it
look like a lot of money and they're out
there and we had we had a production
designer that made our set for landing
home look like just this full studio
Hollywood production and she was
incredibly talented our story deild with
a veteran coming back to his home and
and living with his family and not
having having trouble just struggling
and so we needed to create this
environment of a home of a kitchen of
his daughter's room of the living room
of of him being a veteran pictures and I
would almost say that a production
designer and people would argue with me
but I feel leave from my first project
my production designer was about as
critical as my DP because when you look
when you're in when you're in the
editing phase of your film and you look
at your scenes you are going to notice
if there was production value and if you
had a good production designer if you
look at a scene and you're like wow that
seam looks great and you like the way
the props are and you like the way the
books were stacked and the way the
picture was hanged and the way there was
a plant there that's all production
design once you get a good production
designer on your film you will never
look at a prop in a movie the same way
again you know that when you watch your
TV show and you watch a film that coffee
cup that has happens to be on the desk
was put there for a very specific reason
so get a good production designer
they're incredibly valuable
you need to interview every single
person you bring on your team you need
to know that you can work with that
person that you guys are going to jail
and you need to make sure that they see
your vision and that they understand
that it's your story people are gonna
come on with different ideas and
different visions and they're not gonna
mesh with what you want and again you
have so much on your plate that you want
to make sure that whoever's working with
you is there to support you and they're
to see your vision in your story and
that you can get along with them on set
you just have to find out if you're
gonna gel with that person because the
last thing you want to do is be on set
with whoever a DP a production designer
a PM an ad or a second ad and you're not
getting along with the person because
you just don't have time to stroke
anybody's ego they're kind of being kind
of difficult arguing with you and
they're they have a different vision how
they want to see the project or arguing
with other team members that's gonna
throw your whole set off there's tension
on the set and people are not working
really well and people are starting to
argue and they you just don't have time
for that you really just you want to
eliminate that you want to make sure
that person works well with you and
everyone else on your film set
chemistry is everything for your film
and and if someone says hey I know a
great person for a particular role if
you don't interview them don't hire them
because you got to make sure that
they're not going to mess up your
chemistry on your film set it's really
important that you interview every
single person it's best if you can do it
in person but if you can't do it a
person at minimum do it over the phone
keep your emails organized that is
something that a lot of people
undervalue when creating a project but
as a first-time director it is
incredible incredibly valuable for you
and the lack of stress or the lack of
stress that you're going to have create
a simple structure in your email and
your whatever email system you have and
just create some folders my film was
called landing home I created a folder
called landing home and below that I had
subfolders contracts actors crew team
catering and any time an email comes in
that is corresponding to whatever folder
you you put that fault you put it in
that folder right away because when
you're shooting a project
most of time if you're a first-time
director you're also producing it you're
going to be getting so many emails from
so many different people and it's so
much information and it could feel
overwhelming I mean your inbox could
just be like a disaster zone and you
need to be able to access that
information quickly and efficiently when
you need so by just filing that those
emails away and prompt it and the
appropriate folders take stress away
because you know where things are at you
know where your information is and it
keeps it clear and it clears your mind
and clear your head which allows you to
focus on the things that you need to
focus focus on keep staying organized
with your emails will serve you
incredibly well when you're shooting a
project when we're shooting Landing home
on the first day of shooting our sound
guy didn't show up he kind of basically
just decided to to not show up so we had
a scramble and so staying calm my ad had
some recording device and we were
recorded the scene with what we could I
kept pushing through the scene we just I
didn't tell the actors what was going on
but I went to my folder structure from
when I was cast when I was you know
hiring my when I was hiring a sound
person and I was looking at my email
structures and my emails that had come
in and I was basically reaching out to
other people who had applied for the job
that I had not given the job to and I
was able to do that efficiently and
quickly if I would have kept all those
emails in my inbox so to say it just I
would have never been able to hire
another sound guy that same day and have
am on set for the second half of the day
and that's why you want to stay
organized because it allows you to lead
the project cleanly and efficient I
think being organized specifically with
your emails but being organized in
general is what really allows you to one
have confidence but it allows you to
lead the film as a director put all your
notes or your storyboard illustrations
or your acting notes your your plot
lines your through lines your contracts
your screenshots every single thing that
pertains to your film
put them all in a notebook I went
everywhere on set with this notebook
anytime I had a question about how I
wanted to shoot a scene how I wanted to
direct an actor how I wanted the actor
to act in the scene what the the
intention was of the actor in the scene
I had him in this notebook it's gonna
relieve a tremendous amount of stress
for you so you don't have to worry about
where everything is at and and it's
gonna allow you to be confident onset
because you have all your information
with you and you know you have to keep
there's permits and contracts that you
have to have so put them in the notebook
as well my web series had six episodes
and I broke it down I broke this folder
down into six six major sections and
everything that pertain to that
particular episode those notes those
illustrations those storyboards would go
in that folder and so when we were
shooting a scene that was in that
episode I had opened that folder out I
remind myself what I wanted out of the
scene and I communicate that with the
with the crew and with the cast so get a
notebook and make one for yourself
Condit is set with tons of energy always
come to the set exciting excited
thrilled to be on set even when things
are not going the way you think they're
they should be going say good morning to
everybody be the happiest guy on set
because what you should be happy you're
filming something and it's just a
privilege to film to make a film and to
the whole set leads off of you and make
sure you always thank everybody for for
the work say thank you you know when
they're wrapping up that night everybody
and I mean even the grips every single
person you should go you personally as a
director should say good morning to
everybody and should also thank
everybody everyone leaves off of you and
you know know what's making tons of
money on on these guerilla films and or
projects and by you being gracious and
being respectful
it it it allows them to commit to the
project they feel that you care about
them so they care about what they're
doing on the set and do everything you
can to to treat people with respect and
to have a lot of energy and to say thank
you all the time
and if you can you know if you can find
a way to do it in the budget
you know I bought my crew beer at the
end of every day when we shot Landing
home you know I didn't we didn't have a
party or anything I just I bought like a
case of beer and whenever we wrapped we
would all have a beer as we you know put
things away for them for the night and
we kind of detox a little bit and it was
great because it allowed us to bond as a
team and everyone felt really committed
to the project so if you can do that I
would suggest that you try to do that
get plenty of punch ins as many as you
can shoot people's hands people's legs
shoot you know if you see something
interesting and your gut tells you to
shoot it shoot it even if your whole
crew says that's a dumping to shoot well
we are shooting Landing home I saw a
caterpillar crawling on the floor when
we were outside in the park my character
is a veteran who's struggling coming
back home I thought that was very
symbolic of this caterpillar you know
crawling on the floor - what my
character was going through and so I had
my DP shoot it it looks great
if we had this amazing shot of this
caterpillar really tight shot of him or
it or of it crawling on the floor and
we're gonna use it and it's in the
trailer and it's gonna be used and in
the series and and you can't have enough
punch ends just you know make sure you
get your axis playing with her hair of
people's hands of hands on the wall
get as many punches as you can because
when you're in the editing phase you
just don't know when you're gonna need
that stuff and the last thing you want
to do is be cutting your film going man
I wish I had a little bit more a couple
more reaction side shots or I wish I had
a couple more punch ins I don't have any
more punch ins you know and get b-roll
you know when you're going from location
location tell your DP to turn on his
camera and just record as you're going
down the street you're gonna use that
b-roll you can use that b-roll in 4/4
time lapses in between scenes make sure
that you shoot outside when no one's
outside make sure you shoot in front of
the house when no one's around the house
you know you want all this extra footage
all these extra punches because these
are gonna be like the little bits that
are gonna kind of fill your story out so
shoot it if you think you need it shoot
it if you don't if you think you might
need it shoot it shoot as much as you
possibly can
direct with kindness and what I mean by
that is that be respectful of your
actors ask them what they need and try
to do everything you can to relax them
on set a relaxed actor is a good actor
and acting for 20 years I've been
blessed to pick things up with directors
who I have a lot of respect for that I
could apply to my craft as a director
and I've unfortunately I've been on sets
where directors didn't know how to
direct actors and so I knew exactly what
not to do to my actors I think when you
yell action it should be quiet
you should be you don't need to bark it
out like some egomaniac it should just
be you know action guys because you know
acting is tough but it's tough enough as
it is and and you don't need to kind of
you know get people's anxieties up by
barking action at them and when you give
direction give it to them privately you
know no one else needs to know what the
direction is between you and your actor
I gave every note to all of my actors
privately even when it was good you know
I I didn't need to let everybody else
know what I was trying to communicate
with my with my actor and when you're
always communicating privately to your
actors and every scene throughout the
film shoot the other actors don't feel
like oh he's giving me a note now it
means I'm not a good actor they realized
that this director gives notes privately
after every take after every scene and
it relaxes them they know that this is
the process you know when I've been on
sets when directors have just barked at
me you know trying to say you know make
it it's no good it's you know make it
better you know do something different
really loud and it's just a horrible way
to receive direction I mean that's you
can't be any more vague and vague and I
don't know what to do with that and so
just remember that if you can relax your
actors they're gonna give you amazing
work and when I look at my footage when
I'm cutting it I see relaxed actors I
see actors who are giving it their all
and I tend to I want to think that it's
because I worked so hard to make sure
they felt respected and that they felt
relaxed and so director actors with
kindness your film project will
appreciate it
a little trick that I learned directing
and that I learned as an actor that
works really well on a film set is
improv when your actors are struggling
in a scene
tell them to improv something tell them
to make up a story tell them to talk
about their day tell them to talk about
what they're gonna do for vacation
anything anything that's gonna loosen
them up and get them more grounded and
make them feel like they're human again
because sometimes you know when you're
in the scene and you're not connecting
with it and you're struggling with it as
an actor you just don't you just feel
really weird and and you don't feel
human anymore you feel like you're
trying to create you're trying to force
something down down this to that of
performance that you can't figure out
and a lot of times the way you ground an
actor is just tell them hey you don't
tell me tell her what you're gonna do
tomorrow on your day off or tell her
what your favorite food is what you love
about it and and they start talking
about it and it's amazing how it loosens
them up especially for actors who don't
have improv skill and you can get
anybody to improv and make sure you film
that
and you've filmed that and a lot of
times you can have them improv and film
that and then have them starts to see
then the scene kind of clicks in because
they got connected from the improv and
now they're connected and they're
listening and they're talking to each
other like regular human beings in the
scene so use improv when you feel like
you're getting stuck as a director
and the last thing I want to leave you
with is you're gonna have many sleepless
nights especially during pre-production
before you shoot the film definitely
when you're shooting the film it's all
part of the process you're gonna get
through it get it done I know that I
would wake up in the middle of the night
just almost in a cold sweat freaking out
that what did I get myself into but you
find a way we as creatives we always
find a way to get it done and when
people let you down and you're feeling
completely stressed out and overwhelmed
just be grateful that you're getting the
opportunity to feel these experiences
because it's a privilege to make a film
to make a short film to make a webseries
it's it's an endeavor it's expensive it
takes a lot of hard work and you just
don't know when you're gonna get another
opportunity to do it and especially to
direct your own film so be grateful that
you're in it and know that you're gonna
get it done and when you go to bed every
night before you fall asleep just tell
yourself how grateful you are that your
project has been such a success that
you're grateful that this is the most
successful project that you've ever ever
filmed this is gonna you're grateful
that this there was no hiccups in it you
kind of want to hypnotize yourself and
focus yourself on the outcome of how you
want your film to be and if you do that
I kind of believe that it sends up an
energy out into the creative world and
that the directing and acting gods bless
you
and that's what I did every night even
when I was stressed out I would just
remind myself how grateful I was to my
project was such a success and it's it
came out that way
and we had plenty hiccups we had plenty
of you know storms but we got through it
I got through it and you can get through
it know that you have everything inside
you to finish your project and to get it
done read research prepare yourself and
you'll make it happen
and I wish you nothing but the best of
success and warp speed